donc maintenant on va vérifier ces
manuels goma un problème d'instabilité
interview pied on ne bouge pas pendant
le mandat bush dans la bouche pendant
l'épreuve ne bouge pas pendant le dîneur
connard moi c'est laurent et je suis
ravi de connaître ton prénom votre jeu
que vous êtes mégalo
petit shui un petit show ça veut dire un
petit chou est un petit peu un chouïa
j'apprends ici c'est bien oui c'est bien
là une première tous les samedis sur la
formation technique service public a eu
je vous êtes mito menteuse j'adore sa
parano en ces périodes de l'année un peu
catho normal je vous êtes schizo non
j'ai un wave vrai don d'ubiquité je
préfère ubiquité à schizophrénie nos
frais ni ses plus proches de la pouliche
pas du tout dingue tu arrives à suivre
vous êtes cyclo cyclothymique
ouais mais aujourd'hui c'est quoi ces
apps ou down là à l'instant présent
superbe ce matin c'était totalement
d'armes mais ça va je pleurais j moi
mais c'est pas mal comme la vigne comme
les filles comme nous aussi parce que en
espèces ou aline bordel si elle est pâle
en cinq minutes on y va
or la cure ouais mais j'aime le
classique aussi donc c'est sûr moi je
prends pas du sang vous voulez quoi êtes
vous un petit truc là non le parti de
jude j'aime bien silva préjugés pour
critiquer parce que je vais bien est ce
que vous êtes maso ah non est ce que
vous êtes exhibo quand ça vient petit
chou c'est quoi c'est beaucoup pour
juliette lesbo non petit chien non tout
bord d un pas du tout genre de ça je
vous êtes ado j'adore les ados j'adore
les enfants
gérante au nom c'est vraiment triste
je faisais de trio un trio fuyant
franchement vous êtes quoi je suis très
classique non plus belle pour vous un
adieu en amoureux ouais je m en cô les
grosses grosses lances pas mon truc
vous êtes adamo ah non vous dit tout
et finalement alors donc vous êtes une
fille très très normal qu'ils ne jouent
pas pour aucune perversion
non disent rien les jules et julot way
oui mais voilà
l'enjeu les quatre ans
avec drôle de garde cochet l'émission le
6 juin avec
visuellement et le 12 juin avec
dominique lavanant vous avez que c'est
baffie la bassine irait bien
ces cas là m'ont très vite comme ça je
pourrai juger sur non car j'avais dit
qu'il fallait l'évaluerons qu adam et
laurent il est comme ça lolo n'y revient
pas alors viendra pas il est vexé